why does the nfl have a personal conduct
policy
why does the nfl care about the things
that football players do
away from the football field away from
the football facility away from the team
seven months of an off season on your
own time living your life you get in
trouble with the law there's a
resolution of that situation no jail
time probation whatever the case may be
most other employers
would look the other way it's not our
business oh the only thing that matters
to us is are you able to show up and
work and if it gets to a point where you
can't show up and work because you're
incarcerated then we have to deal with
this employment issue now look some
employers will blur that line and there
are instances where you need to blow
that line if you're a bus driver you had
a dui probably something that will
affect your ability to continue to drive
a bus but for most employers
you have an incident away from work it
doesn't affect your ability to show up
and work it's none of the employer's
business it's between the employee and
the criminal justice system the nfl
decided as a matter of pr they decided
it was good for business to care about
and actively police the things that
players do away from work and that is
something that had been lingering and
lingering and in 2007 thanks to pacman
jones and the late chris henry the nfl
ramped up the punishment specifically
for guys who have multiple incidents
even if they're never arrested even if
they're never charged even if they've
never spent a day in jail multiple
incidents will get you in trouble more
quickly than a scattered accusation
allegation or confrontation somewhere
out in public so
that was the way things worked from 2007
until 2014 then came ray rice and what
happened with ray rice
the nfl initially suspended him two
games based upon the information that
was available to the nfl including a
video that we all saw of
ray rice's then fiancee knocked out cold
on the floor of an elevator as ray rice
was standing there apparently trying to
figure out what to do next now
after that two-game suspension was
announced there was some blowback there
was some harsh criticism of the
commissioner for only suspending ray
rice for two games
then came the video that the nfl either
did or didn't have or either knew or
should have known what was on that video
i mean we knew she was knocked out
somehow she got knocked out and then we
see the video the punch that knocked her
out and the nfl essentially ends ray
rice's career and that was the moment
because the commissioner's career was
almost ended in the aftermath of the
emergence of that video remember it was
the day after the start of the 2014
season all hell broke loose and and the
nfl should have been doing a victory lap
after a great week one of action instead
the nfl was reeling for a couple of
weeks the commissioner had to worry that
his
time as the man in charge of the sport
was over and i think at that moment he
decided that he'll never be accused
again of going too softly on
a player who was accused of doing
something away from work especially when
it involves any type of domestic
violence we saw the personal conduct
policy get beefed up there was the
adrian peterson situation the greg hardy
situation and as of 2014 the nfl was
ready to pounce on any player accused of
any type of misconduct especially
involving family members wives
girlfriends children etc so fast forward
to 2017.
that was when the nfl decided to throw
the book at ezekiel elliott based upon
what i believe was flimsy evidence and a
poor procedure not aimed at giving
ezekiel a fair shot at at defending
himself the nfl was determined to
suspend him for six games again the
commissioner was never going to be
accused of going too softly on a player
who got into trouble off the field so
six games period that's it well
what happened in 2017 was two things
first of all the tv ratings continued to
plummet after 2016 when the ratings
first dropped due to the presidential
election on top of that in the aftermath
of the ezekiel suspension what happened
cowboys owner jerry jones went after the
commissioner remember all of that
commissioner was negotiating a new
contract jerry jones was trying to get
that derailed jerry jones wanted to get
rid of the commissioner and so
the pendulum now
which had swung very sharply in favor of
over punishing players now it starts
moving in the other direction and i
think it was a combination of the
assault by jerry jones on the
commissioner and the idea that the tv
ratings are down what do we do to
increase and enhance the tv ratings well
one of the things you do is you make
sure the best players in the nfl are
available to play ezekiel elliott was
gone from the team that is the biggest
draw on national television for 37.5
percent of the entire regular season
when that six game suspension finally
began so i think the nfl decided and
they didn't announce it they never would
announce it but they decided to be more
lenient with players who potentially
won't be allowed to play due to
violation of the personal conduct policy
or
the substance abuse policy because
that's where we first noticed this shift
it was with josh gordon martavis bryant
and randy gregory last year as those
three guys were reinstated after
suspensions of at least a year and there
were reports and there were accounts of
additional issues and problems and
positive tests and under the league's
procedures
they should have been abruptly thrown
out of the game for another minimum of
one year but they weren't see i feel
like the nfl and i firmly believe the
nfl has decided that
it's in the interest of the business to
have the best possible players play
football that that's what results in the
ratings going up and ultimately
recovering from that slump in 2016 and
2017 so that's where they are now and
that's the background and that's why i
believe the nfl which easily could have
suspended tyree kill for four games
eight games 12 games whatever the nfl
has realized that the potential impact
on tv ratings and thus on the business
of not having hill available to play is
greater than the potential impact on the
business of letting hill play and
dealing with whatever the fallout may be
and really what will the fallout be will
there be protests will there be
demonstrations will there be a call for
a boycott of the nfl because the nfl
didn't suspend tyree kill they've tried
to thread this needle in a way that
enhances the business and you know it's
it's the league version of what we
always say as it relates to individual
teams with individual teams they find a
way to make an excuse for a great player
so the great player can continue to play
the nfl used to be immune from that now
i think we see the league recognizing
we need to have great players on the
field
that if we don't have great players on
the field
and if we're coming up with reasons to
keep great players off the field we are
hurting our business bottom line that's
why tyree kill wasn't suspended and i
believe that if this had happened two
years ago he would have been suspended
just like ezekiel elliott was and if you
flip it if hill did what he did two
years ago
and elliott did what he did this year
elliot wouldn't have been suspended he
would have been the beneficiary of this
realization that it's in the nfl's best
interests to keep great players on the
field and not concoct reasons to
arbitrarily throw them out of the sport
whether it's one game whether it's one
year whether it's one series they want
the best players on the field and that's
why tyree kill wasn't suspended
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports